the next atomic bomb is made of DNA and
it's as affordable as a new car in
recent years genetic data has become
more available knowledge more widespread
and lab resources less expensive
bioengineering had previously been
restricted to well-funded Laboratories
where research produced Marvel's like
gene therapy and covid-19 vaccines but
now it's getting increasingly open to
anyone willing to spend a year salary on
lab equipment that includes people who
want to do harm who are poorly trained
in safety or just reckless from
terrorist attacks to lab accidents the
effects of a loose engineered virus
could be devastating in 1945 the
Manhattan Project spawned the threat of
nuclear Annihilation while
simultaneously providing the key to
nuclear power biotech is just as
threatening today and few people are
even aware of how powerful it's become
and will become in the next few years we
don't have decades to do something about
it we must act now but how watch the
full video on our channel to find out